let me be clear the United Nations is
not leaving Sudan
our commitment is to the Sudanese people
in support of their wishes for a
peaceful and secure future since they
started fighting on 15 April
hundreds of people have been killed and
thousands injured
the violence must stop
it risks a catastrophic conflagration
within Sudan
that could engulf the All Region and
Beyond
I strongly condemned indiscriminate
bombardment of Civilian areas including
Healthcare facilities
and I call on the parties to stop combat
operations in densely populated areas
and to allow any humanitarian Aid
operations
civilians must be able to access food
water and other essential supplies and
evacuate from combat zones
I am in constant contact with the
parties to the conflict and I've called
on them to de-escalate tensions and to
return to the negotiating table
we'll continue our efforts with our
partners to secure a permanent halt to
the fighting as soon as possible
working with the military organizations
on the ground we are reconfiguring our
presence in Sudan to enable us to
continue supporting the Sudanese people
we stand with them at this terrible time